okay everyone shut up immediately today
starting a new revenge mission our
target boom hey I'll go to the
principal's office right now you two you
sick effective minions look we we didn't
do anything
yeah yeah hey Durban I gotta send three
kids to your office right now why they
were kissing each other yeah all three
of them were just sitting here doing
kissing right here in the middle of the
classroom ABC was crazy I couldn't
believe it
anyway it was gross here they come out
yep
have fun explaining that who wants to
strike out last night he's angry as hell
now as you may have heard Marcus refuses
to bring back my chips so our mission is
to replace Marcus kasparek as student
council president can't you just buy
chips at the store what's not about
chips anymore Sarika this is about
principle okay and it is a little bit
about the chips I do love chips
it's about 6040 principle two chips at
this point for me I get it yeah haveit
gets it Thank You Heather so I read the
student council bylaws we only need 200
signatures to her call Marcus and
replace it with a new candidate so today
we're gonna be choosing that new
candidate it seems like an overreaction
all right well tarik is eliminated so I
want to hear you guys pitch yourselves
campaign-style
Anthony you start I was president I'd
make all the dances of prom slow dances
I'm paying 20 bucks I want to feel a
body there you go good point okay who's
next Colin I don't know if I'm the right
choice there's a pretty damning video
out there of me blowing out at another
kid's birthday candles they got excited
okay anybody else have any skeletons in
their closet i shoplift magazines to
feel alive getting cuts the fun part you
know what look why don't we skip past
this and just move on to the person with
the most charisma dan Decker you in yeah
I mean actually did student council back
in Florida sod let a help blah blah blah
blah blah yeah okay don't ruin it all
right uh guys Dan Decker's our candidate
let's go out let's get those signatures
okay pass those down I want you to be
subtle but I want you to be efficient
with each passing minute the chips gets
Taylor and staler
I thought this was supposed to be a
rooftop garden
apparently the weight of the soil have
made the gym roof collapse we almost
killed a lot during people mulch
I got mulch hey Jack you know I saw the
most curious thing yesterday Dan Becker
chatting up the Spanish club at first I
was very confused and then I realized
what he was doing according the Latino
vote I think that clubs mostly white
kids
Victor shut up anyway I passed an
emergency resolution to replace the
president it now requires 10,000
signatures it's art jack mark my words
you soulless taint I will take you down
you'll be out office before you see a
single precious tomato grow or sooner
but you know how long it takes tomatoes
to grow well depending on the size and
the soil by the way we had to find a
place for some gardening supplies might
make parking a little bit of a mess see
you jack
[Music]
Marcus
you